bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre en direct
les questions cribles thématiques sur le
thème de la situation de la médecine
libérale
en france les questions cribles
thématiques vous le savez c'est
l'occasion pour les sénateurs de poser
leurs questions à un membre du
gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est la ministre de la
santé marisol touraine qui va affronter
les différents intervenants au sénat les
échanges s'annoncent musclées alors que
de nombreux médecins libéraux ont prévu
de manifester le 15 mars prochain contre
le projet de loi de santé de marisol
touraine
un projet de loi santé qui devraient
être au coeur des questions des
sénateurs avec des thèmes comme le tiers
payant les conditions d'exercice de la
médecine libérale et sa place dans notre
système de soins je vous retrouve pour
ma part à la fin des questions cribles
pour faire le point tout de suite
retrouvé les questions cribles
thématiques en direct dans l'hémicycle
il public sénat et pour commencer la
première des questions sera celle de
bâle à michel meunier
pour le groupe socialiste l'avait la
parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je sais l'engagement du
gouvernement et votre volonté de
construire des solutions concrètes face
à la désertification médicale qui
pénalise de nombreux citoyens dans notre
pays vous avez madame la ministre dans
le cadre du pacte territoire santé
engagés en 2012 décidé de réformes de
fond qui ne manqueront pas de porter
leur des fruits à court et à moyen terme
outre les réformes de la formation
médicale les accompagnements à
l'installation le développement du
travail en réseau qui ont sont autant
d'avancé vous avez aussi soutenu le
développement des maisons de santé
ces centres pluridisciplinaires
représente une solution aux besoins de
la population notamment dans les
secteurs en désertification médicale ou
en risque de le devenir
l'aféas la fédération des établissements
hospitaliers et des aides à la personne
recommandé soutient fortement cette
orientation
pourriez vous madame la ministre mme
indiqué l'état des lieux et le plan de
développement de ces maisons de santé à
l'échelon national
par ailleurs à l'occasion de la loi de
santé
les inquiétudes s'expriment tant du
point de vue du corps médical qui craint
de ne plus pouvoir s'installer librement
que de celui des patients et des
patients qui se verraient imposer un
médecin pourriez vous nous préciser
madame la ministre
quel est votre orientation en matière de
liberté d'exercice de la médecine et de
liberté de choix pour les patients
merci aux parents le top marisol
touraine ministre de la santé l'avait la
parole madame hominis merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice michel
meunier
vous avez souligné l'importance que le
gouvernement accorde à la présence
médicale dans l'ensemble de nos
territoires
et c'est vrai que depuis quelques années
nous sommes confrontés dans certains
territoires un manque de professionnels
de santé des médecins mais pas
uniquement des médecins je veux
l'indiqué d'autres professionnels de
santé je veux insister sur les principes
qui fondent l'organisation de la
médecine libérale et auquel vous avez
fait allusion à la fin de votre
intervention
la liberté d'installation des médecins
n'a pas été n'est pas et ne sera pas
remise en cause par le gouvernement est
la meilleure preuve en est que le pacte
territoire santé qui a été élaboré il ya
maintenant un peu plus de deux ans pour
permettre l'installation de jeunes ou
moins jeunes d'ailleurs professionnelle
dans nos territoires
c'est tout entier concentré sur des
mesures d'incitation c'est-à-dire
d'attractivité le pari que fait le
gouvernement c'est de rendre plus
attractifs les conditions d'exercice des
professionnels de santé libéraux pour
valoriser et mieux reconnaître cette
médecine libérale donc liberté
d'installation des médecins liberté
évidemment qui va de pair du choix de
son médecin par le patient
et c'est ainsi que nous encourageons les
médias mettent maison
pluri professionnelle de santé en 2012
il y en avait moins de 270 environ elles
sont plus de 600 aujourd'hui 200 devrait
ouvrir en 2015 c'est une révolution
concrètes dans l'accès aux soins c'est
une manière de travailler qui répond aux
attentes des professionnels aux attentes
de nos concitoyens
et c'est dans ce sens que j'ai
l'intention de continuer à oeuvrer avec
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
si madame la ministre madame michelle
meunier
madame la ministre de ces propos qui
viennent lever certaines ambiguïtés ou
malentendus notamment sur la liberté
d'installation et la liberté du choix de
son médecin
quant aux maisons de santé je ne doute
pas que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
travailler dans votre projet de
l'e-santé prochainement merci mais si la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
gérard roche pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants union
centriste avait la parole mon cher
collègue le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ma question portera
plus sur la médecine générale au fil des
décennies notre système de santé de plus
en plus performants sur caen technique
et donc de plus en plus spécialisés ce
qui correspond à l'évolution naturelle
des besoins santé d'un pays moderne mais
au fur et à mesure que ces tendances
affirmées la médecine généraliste s'est
senti dévalorisé
cette médecine est pourtant essentiel
constituent les fondations nos systèmes
de santé
elle prend en charge la globalité des
personnes et l'accompagnent dans son
parcours de soins en conséquence le
champ de compétence entendu du médecin
généraliste est toujours prêt d'argent
multidisciplinaire englobant bien sûr
l'urgence la pédiatrie aiguë pour ne
citer que ces exemples
dans ces conditions le manque d'attrait
susciter chez les jeunes qui se lancent
dans cette profession est extrêmement
problématique
sa concrétisation en spécialité à part
entière n'a hélas pas assez changé les
choses et de médecine générale reste
encore insuffisamment reconnue elle doit
être valorisée cette revalorisation de
report se faire sur plusieurs plans
celui de la formation bien sûr puisque
le médecin généraliste doit pouvoir
faire face à des fonctions réelles
d'urgentistes de pédiatres de
psychiatres et cetera comme je viens de
le dire
la question de la rémunération suppose
mais n'est pas essentiel à mon avis la
surcharge de travail administratif
compte également et cet argument a été
largement développée lors des dernières
grèves ce qui entre en jeu de façon
majeure c'est la solitude pour assurer
le poids des responsabilités
la fatigue voire l'usure de devoir
assumer la permanence des soins
madame la ministre vous favoriser les
regroupements dans des maisons médicales
et nous nous en félicitons
mais l'angoissé nos populations face à
la désertification médicale reste très
grande et il m'a semblé important de
vous entendre sujets dans le contexte
actuel pour nous dire quelles actions
vous entendez menée pour revaloriser la
médecine généraliste
madame la ministre je me permets de vous
le demander car à titre personnel je
puis attester qu'il s'agit d'un métier
très exigeant mais aussi d'un très beau
métier et pour certains endroits du
métier d'une vocation dont le dr rush
vous questionne madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur docteur roche
je veux vous dire que vous avez raison
d'insister sur l'importance de la
médecine générale et des médecins
généralistes parce que l'on parle de la
médecine générale mais derrière ce terme
il y à des femmes des hommes engagés au
quotidien auprès de leurs patients et je
veux ici de façon très solennelle
réaffirmé l'importance de ces médecins
généralistes qui sont le plus souvent
d'ailleurs nos médecins traitants dans
la loi que je porte parce que l'un des
enjeux c'est de faire en sorte que leur
rôle soit mieux valoriser mieux
identifier mieux reconnus dans le
parcours de soins et dans l'organisation
des soins de proximité cela passe par
une valorisation de la formation des
futurs médecins généralistes et pour
cela que j'ai insisté sur la nécessité
de faire des stages et de multiplier le
nombre de médecins qui sont maîtres de
stage les résultats sont là les deux
tiers des étudiants ont effectué un
stage de médecine générale en 2014 ils
étaient 40 % seulement en 2011 et cela
leur donne le goût de ce métier j'ai par
ailleurs demandé au professeur pierre
louis de rue mais qui est le président
du collège de la médecine générale de me
faire des propositions pour
prolonger ses actions et renforcer la
place de la médecine générale
je veux rappeler également que des
revalorisations sont intervenus à
travers des forfaits que j'ai mise en
place en 2012 pour les médecins
traitants forfait pour l'ensemble des
patients suivis par ses médecins
revalorisation spécifique de la
consultation pour les personnes âgées
qui est plus souvent pratiquées par les
médecins généralistes il y a eu donc là
des actes de revalorisation financière
concrète à destination des médecins
traitants médecins généralistes dont je
veux réaffirmer avec vous la place
centrale dans notre système de soins
merci madame le ministre gérard roche
juste un mot pour remercier madame la
ministre qui a dit les mots que nous
attendions avec une audience en dha très
bien passée ta bonheur la parole est
maintenant notre collègue isabelle debré
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre tout
d'abord je souhaite réaffirmer notre
attachement à la médecine libérale et la
confiance que nous lui portons la
médecine libérale c'est la liberté pour
le médecin de choisir les modalités
d'exercice de son activité
mais c'est aussi la liberté pour le
patient de choisir son médecin traitant
cette liberté est malheureusement mis à
mal par le projet de loi relatifs à la
santé que vous avez présenté le 15
octobre dernier les protestations et la
mobilisation des professionnels de santé
vous ont néanmoins contrainte madame la
ministre a reporté l'examen de votre
projet de loi quelles sont les raisons
profondes de cette mobilisation
tout d'abord le manque de concertation
avec la profession ce qu'a d'ailleurs
reconnu notre collègue député socialiste
et rapporteur général gérard bapt
par ailleurs les médecins ont la
douloureuse impression que l'état vient
de rompre le contrat passé avec les
professionnels libéraux
en effet comment ne pas voir à travers
la réforme proposée une forme
d'étatisation poussée de la médecine de
ville pour renouer le dialogue et
relancer la concertation
vous avez mis en place quatre groupes de
travail or cette concertation via une
nouvelle fois de prendre fin avec le
départ des principaux syndicats de
médecins libéraux
des groupes de travail notamment celui
sur le service public hospitalier
pourquoi parce que le service public
hospitalier que vous proposez de mettre
en oeuvre et profondément inégalitaire
au détriment de la médecine libérale
dans ce contexte madame la ministre mais
question sont les suivantes
allez vous revenir sur les sujets qui
inquiètent l'ensemble des professionnels
libéraux
quels seront les ce prix est le contenu
réel du texte sur lequel le parlement
sera amené à travailler
et quel sera le calendrier retenu
je vous remercie madame le ministre de
la santé vous avez la parole oui merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice isabelle debré je réaffirme à
nouveau comme je lé fais il ya quelques
instants
mon attachement aux principes qui sont
ceux de la médecine libérale et ma
confiance dans les professionnels de
santé libéraux les médecins mais encore
une fois l'ensemble des professionnels
parce que notre système s'appuie aussi
repose aussi sur les infirmiers les
kinésithérapeutes et orthophonistes les
sages femmes les pharmaciens et bien
d'autres encore liberté d'installation
liberté du professionnel du choix du
professionnel par les patients et je
veux dire je veux rappeler que l'enjeu
de la loi que je porte c'est de répondre
à la montée de certaines inégalités de
santé un rapport récent a indiqué que
l'état de santé global de la population
française était bon mais que derrière
ces moyennes se cachait en quelque sorte
ne se cache pas vraiment des inégalités
modernisation donc de notre système de
santé par le renforcement de la
prévention par le renforcement de la
médecine de proximité notamment à
travers la confiance accordée à la
médecine générale et puis par
modernisation par le soutien aux
patients une concertation s'est engagé
notamment sur les soins de proximité qui
est un très fructueuse et qui en dehors
des
caméra se passe de manière extrêmement
positive et je retiendrai beaucoup des
propositions qui sont faites parce que
je considère qu'elle enrichit le texte
de loi que je propose sur la place des
médecins de proximité sur leur rôle dans
et leur mobilisation pour proposer des
projets de coopération et donc je veux
vous rassurer madame la sénatrice le
travail se poursuit il se poursuit bien
et il permettra d'améliorer sensiblement
la rédaction de la loi sur un certain
nombre de sujets qui préoccupent les
professionnels de santé aujourd'hui
merci madame la ministre madame la
présidente oui madame la mini je ne suis
pas certaine d'avoir été rassurés mais
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que vous pouvez compter sur nous
pour défendre le maintien en france
d'une médecine libérale d'excellence
nous veillerons aussi à ce que la
liberté de choix des patients choix de
leur médecin choix de leurs
établissements privés ou publics soient
sauvegardés et ça vous pourrez compter
sur nous mais la ministre
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant notre collègue gilbert
barbier pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole
merci j'ai donné dans madame la ministre
mes chers collègues depuis pour kraft la
médecine est un art l'art de comprendre
les maladies et de les prévenir de les
guérir ou de les soulager
nous avec l'avènement de l'ère de
scientifiques avec le développement de
techniques d'investigations
complémentaires de plus en plus
sophistiqués l'augmentation du nombre
des spécialisations la médecine
serait-elle de lui une science la
relation entre le médecin et le malade
au coeur du processus thérapeutique est
mise à mal
le médecin d'autrefois qui connaissait
l'histoire du patient et prenez le temps
de les écouter ou laisser la place des
techniciens des prescripteurs les
patients se sont transformé en client en
consommateurs de soins le dialogue
singulier réduit à sa plus simple
expression face à une dualité
difficilement conciliables entre la
médecine en tant que telle celle qu'elle
fonde en nous mêmes de la médecine
libérale et la politique de santé qui
concerne bien sûr les pouvoirs publics
et les financeurs
la question est bien de savoir où se
situe le curseur pour respecter les
droits et les devoirs des uns et des
autres faut-il être en conflit permanent
sachant bien sûr que les pouvoirs
publics sont en position de force
essentiellement par le contrôle du
financement rompre cet équilibre subtil
par exemple avec le tiers payant
généralisé ou d'autres contacts
administrative risquer de faire basculer
ce qui reste de la liberté dans ce
secteur vers une organisation étatique
où ce mot liberté n'aura plus de sens
est ce que dans ce système le patient
qui doit être content seule
préoccupation il trouvera son compte
je n'en suis pas certain au delà du
problème de la santé nous en sommes dans
un débat idéologique philosophique et je
sois très madame la ministre connaître
peu comment vous aborder cette question
fondamentale
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
pour répondre à la question de monsieur
barbier
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le sénateur barbier beaucoup de
questions en réalité dans l'intervention
que vous avez fait parce que je peux
vous rejoindre sur la nécessité de
valoriser la médecine humaniste la
médecine clinique aujourd'hui qui a
parfois tendance à être moins valorisé
moins identifiés ou un reconnu qu une
médecine plus technicienne qui pour
autant est nécessaire lorsque l'on pense
par exemple à la radiologie à l'imagerie
ou à la chirurgie et qui peut dire qu'il
faut opposées l'une à l'autre puisque
nous avons évidemment aussi besoin de
ces actes techniques qui font partie
intégrante de la médecine même si en
répondant à monsieur roche en répondant
à madame meunier ou même à madame debré
à l'instant et en insistant sur la place
de la médecine générale
j'ai bien voulu indiquer que c'est cette
relation particulière du médecin avec
son malade
cette relation qui permet d'écouter mais
aussi de se livrer à l'examen clinique
qui est la porte d'entrée dans notre
système
de santé et puis vous avez évoqué
d'autres sujets qui au fond sont assez
éloigné de celui là qui consiste à vous
inquiéter de la nuit sous tutelle
excessive de des professionnels de santé
et des médecins de la part des
financeurs et au fond vous posez la
question qui agite parfois les médecins
qui inquiète certains d'entre eux de la
mise en place possible par les
organismes complémentaires par exemple
de réseaux de soins je veux profiter de
l'occasion que vous me donnez pour dire
qu'il n'ya pas de réseau de soins qui
concerne les médecins qu'il n'y aura pas
et qu'il n'y a pas dans la loi de santé
qu'il n'y aura pas de disposition
soumettant les médecins libéraux à des
prescriptions si j'ose dire de la part
des complémentaires de santé ce qui
n'exclut évidemment pas de la part de
l'assurance maladie
la régulation des dépenses de santé que
vous appelez par ailleurs de vos voeux à
l'occasion des débats réguliers sur les
financement de la sécurité sociale
notre collègue gilbert barbier pour
répondre merci de ces propos un petit
peu rassurant à madame la ministre on
nous verrons au moment de la discussion
de cette fois je crois qu'il ya un point
quand même fondamental qu'il faut
aborder ce la formation initiale qui
pour le patient pose un problème
véritable l'art médical
certes c'est un art de soins c'est aussi
un art d'accompagnement ce qui me ce qui
me semble un peu en contradiction avec
la politique de prime à la performance
qui est mise en place il ya été mise en
place il ya quelques années
ce nouveau mode de rémunération comporte
à mon sens un véritable risque de
stérilisation de l'initiative et en
raison de la tendance à récompenser le
conformisme gelé des la médecine est un
art votre système a tendance à gommer
l'excellence a nié la notoriété acquise
par la qualité des praticiens comme
votre acharnement concernant les
contraintes d'installation corée qui ont
été évoqués et contre les dépassements
d'honoraires où il aurait seulement
fallu traiter les dépassements
manifestement abusif
je pense que le nivellement par le bas à
vers lequel nous allons ne se fera pas
au bénéfice des patients
merci la parole et knock maintenant
notre collègue aline archambault pour le
groupe écologiste avait la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues ma question porte sur la
médiation sanitaire la médecine libérale
se heurte aujourd'hui à une double
difficulté d'un côté les médecins se
plaignent de tâches administratives de
plus en plus lourdes
beaucoup craignent d'ailleurs que la
généralisation du tiers payant en
amplifie ce phénomène comme cette mesure
est selon nous est indispensable et je
salue d'ailleurs madame la ministre
votre opiniâtreté sur le sujet il faut
trouver une solution pour la mettre en
oeuvre sans pour autant complexifier les
conditions d'exercice des médecins dans
l'autre côté les patients notamment les
plus modestes se heurte aussi à des
difficulté difficultés d'accès aux
droits sociaux aux soins et à la santé
une partie de la solution doit me
semble-t-il reposer sur le développement
de nouveaux métiers et notamment ceux de
la médiation sanitaire qui vise à
améliorer l'accès au droit à la
prévention et aux soins
les professionnels de la médiation
sanitaire travail à la fois avec les
patients avec les professionnels de
santé avec les administrations et les
services publics
il joue le rôle d'interface pour
construire à terme un accès facilité aux
systèmes de droit commun alors madame la
ministre ma question est double
premièrement comment inciter les
médecins libéraux à s'appuyer davantage
sur les professionnels de la médiation
sanitaires les nouveaux modes de
rémunération ne pourrait-il pas intégré
ce critère
deuxièmement avez vous l'intention de
permettre que ces métiers soient
reconnus de leur donner un vrai statut
et de développer des filières de
formation initiale et continue à ces
métiers
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
madame marisol touraine ministre de la
santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice aline archimbaud je veux
saluer j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
faire votre opiniâtreté aussi à lutter
contre les inégalités de santé et
c'était tout l'enjeu du très remarquable
rapport que
avait remis au premier ministre jean
marc ayrault il y à quelques temps et
qui inspire certaines des dispositions
de la loi de santé
ce matin même le premier ministre manuel
valls recevait j'étais présente à ses
côtés le comité alertent les
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
et qui évoquait comme vous le faites la
nécessité de mettre en avant des
dispositifs qui permettent d'accompagner
les personnes les plus éloignées du
système de santé vers les soins
notamment en favorisant ce que vous
appelez de vos voeux la médiation
sanitaires et c'est pour cela que sera
financé dans le cadre du plan pauvreté
des mesures seront financées par dont
des mesures de médiation sanitaires un
dispositif nouveau et que ce dispositif
sera reconnu explicitement dans la loi
de santé qui permettra d expérimentation
à la matière de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit concrètement de permettre aux
acteurs de terrain à quels qu'ils soient
des collectivités locales des
associations des professionnels de santé
tout organisme qui intervient dans le
champ des soins ou de la prévention de
s'engager pour accompagner des personnes
qui sont éloignés des dispositifs de
soins qui sont éloignés des hôpitaux des
médecins et qui ont besoin d'y être d'en
être rapprochée dans le même temps je
vais confier à la haute autorité de
santé
la mission d'élaborer un cadre pour
définir la formation de ces
professionnels un cadre de référence en
matière de compétences et permettant
aussi ce cadre de préciser les modalités
déontologique de l'intervention vous le
voyez madame la sénatrice
je suis comme vous l'êtes très attentive
à ce que la médiation sanitaire puis se
développer voilà mme archambault
je vous remercie madame la ministre de
votre réponse et surtout de ce que vous
nous indiquait comme mesures concrètes
si j'ai bien compris bientôt
opérationnels pour reconnaître une
pratique professionnelle qui existe
aujourd'hui
parfois dans certains endroits depuis
depuis dix ans mais avec des métiers qui
ont le temps ne sont pas reconnus
doivent êtres dont les porteurs doivent
chaque année chercher des financements
parce que c'est très compliqué et les
formations sont en effet aujourd'hui
encore dans quelques universités mettra
donc je vous remercie je vous remercie
plus généralement de comprendre notre
préoccupation l'ouverture enfin la
facilitation de l'accès au droit et
l'accès à la santé ne doivent pas selon
nous être vus comme des dépenses
supplémentaires mais bien comme un
investissement comme un investissement
qui permet assez vite d'ailleurs de
faire que les personnes sont moins
malades et donc également que sur le
plan financier
les pouvoirs publics ont moins de
dépenses je vous remercie
merci ma chère collègue la parole
maintenant le pro collègue laurence
cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la situation de la
médecine libérale ne peut être
déconnecté de l'organisation notre
système de santé dans la complémentarité
la coopération et non la concurrence qui
dit organisation dit notamment
organisation territoriale
ce qui nous conduit à bord d une réalité
connue de toutes et de tous notamment
dans cet hémicycle celle des déserts
médicaux
le sénat a d'ailleurs produit un rapport
d'information sur cette question en
février 2013
on sait que la répartition disparates
sur le territoire des professionnels de
santé rend plus difficile l'accès aux
soins pour les citoyens et engendre de
véritable inégalité
force est de constater qu'il ya des
déserts médicaux dans quasiment tous les
départs team départements ruraux comme
urbain il concerne aussi bien les
médecins généralistes que les
spécialistes et globalement tous les
professionnels de santé
je ne peux malheureusement pas
intervenir longuement sur les travaux du
géographe emmanuel vigneron qui met en
évidence combien l'accès aux
établissements de santé aux urgences est
très variable et a des répercussions
évidentes sur la santé de nos
concitoyens
tout ceci pose la question de la
nécessaire articulation entre la
médecine libérale et les centres de
santé notamment
or les centres de santé ne sont pas
soutenues alors qu'ils permettent une
proximité de soins et ont le mérite
d'offrir
réponse complémentaire au système actuel
à la fois pour des professionnels de
santé qui ne souhaite pas exercer en
libéral et pour des patients qui
trouvent dans ces centres une réponse
satisfaisante tant d'un point de vue de
la qualité de la prise en charge que de
la possibilité de pouvoir bénéficier du
tiers payant intégral dès lors ma d'un
ami nice vous poserai des questions
complémentaires l'une touche le nombre
insuffisant de professionnels de santé
avec leur répartition
l'autre la pratique médicale elle-même
envisagez vous de changer le mode de
calcul du numerus clausus absent de
votre pack territoire santé de votre
projet de loi santé en ne partant plus
du principe de plafond qui limite mais
plutôt d'un plancher minimum qui
assurait un nombre suffisant de
professionnels médicaux et paramédicaux
quelles mesures incitatives pour une
installation dans les zones mal
desservies et quels moyens allez vous
mettre en oeuvre pour conforter et
développer les centres de santé
au lieu de les mettre en concurrence
avec les maisons de santé qui répondent
à d'autres missions je vous remercie
pour vous répondre pour l'état madame
marisol touraine ministre de la santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice laurence cohen les enjeux de
désertification médicale renvoie à la
mise en place de structures qui soit
attractif pour les professionnels
libéraux ou à l'implantation de centres
de santé je ne crois pas je ne veux pas
insister sur ce point parce que je veux
répondre sur les centres de santé je ne
crois pas que le numerus clausus soit la
réponse principale puisque les enjeux
sont ceux de la répartition des
professionnels sur le territoire
plus que de leur nombre j'aurai
l'occasion très prochainement par une
visite de marquer ma reconnaissance et
l'importance que j'accorde au centre de
santé dans notre système de soins ils
sont un partenaire indispensable dans
certains territoires mais au-delà de ces
territoires dans notre système de
manière plus générale et je veux dire
que j'ai souhaité que les centres de
santé soient prises en compte au même
titre que les maisons
pluriprofessionnelle libéral en tenant
compte de leurs spécificités pour ce qui
est de leurs financements ainsi des
négociations spécifiques sur la
rémunération des équipes dans les
centres de santé
ont engagé avec l'assurance maladie et
la loi de santé reconnaîtra et
facilitera leur financement par
l'assurance maladie donc dans quelques
semaines il y a peu de temps j'ai
annoncé que je voulais valoriser leurs
compétences en leur permettant par
exemple de pratiquer des interruptions
volontaires de grossesse instrumental
dès lors bien sûr que les conditions de
sécurité sont respectées
j'ai demandé aux agences régionales de
santé de favoriser la mise en place de
centres de santé dans les territoires où
c'est nécessaire il ya par exemple en
ile de france plus de 300 centres de
santé d'ores et déjà et un programme de
développement existent vous le voyez
madame la sénatrice les centres de santé
ont un rôle majeur à jouer dans l'offre
de soin en direction des patients et
c'est un rôle que je souhaite
reconnaître et conforté je vous remercie
madame la ministre je vais pas épiloguer
sur le numerus clausus qui s'adresse à
tous les professionnels je suis moi-même
orthophoniste en exercice et je peux
vous dire qu'il manque des
orthophonistes dans ce pays et sur tous
les territoires
la deuxième chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que je suis vraiment ravi que vous
souteniez dans cet hémicycle les centres
de santé je suis moi-même signataires de
l'appel pacte d'avenir des centres de
santé et je pense que c'est très
important effectivement d'avoir un appui
au niveau de votre ministère ce que je
souhaite c'est que cet appui ne soit pas
seulement morale effectivement mais
qu'il ait des incidences en soutenant en
termes de moyens financiers et de moyens
humains et j'espère également que les
vingt recommandations qui ont été
préconisées par le rapport de l'igas
soit aussi suivi et puisse mettre être
mise en application à saint
effectivement d'impulser un mouvement de
développement des centres de santé dans
tous les territoires et pour toutes les
populations qui en ont besoin et je
crois que c'est un appel aujourd'hui à
la suite de ce débat je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant la dame a
même ri dumas pour le groupe socialiste
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre
parmi toutes les mesures prises par le
gouvernement en décembre 2012
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
et favoriser l'implantation des médecins
libéraux dans les territoires classés en
zone prioritaire d'exercice la création
du contrat de praticiens territoriale de
médecine générale devait permettre à de
jeunes praticiens de s'installer dans
les zones sous dotées en sécurisant
financièrement et socialement les
premiers mois d'installation
après deux années de fonctionnement du
pacte territoire santé on constate sur
le terrain que c'était des tout temps
d'autant plus efficaces qu'elles se
complètent par la possibilité donnée aux
jeunes médecins d'exercer au sein d'une
maison de santé pluridisciplinaire et
que la combinaison de ces deux mesures a
permis une amélioration sensible de la
situation des zones défavorisées en
matière d'offre médicale par ailleurs
les difficultés constatées en matière de
médecine générale existe également en
matière d'accès aux consultations de
spécialistes
et si la densité de généralistes varie
de 1 à 2 sur le territoire national
celle des spécialistes varie de 1 à 7
avec une réelle pénurie dans certaines
spécialités dans les départements ruraux
notamment qui ont conduit les
collectivités locales à s'engager dans
des expérimentations de médecins des
deux maisons des spécialistes pardon sur
le modèle des maisons médicales
quelles améliorations attendez vous
madame la ministre de la création dans
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2015 du contrat de
praticiens territoriale de médecine
ambulatoire et pouvez vous nous dire
quels sont les objectifs chiffrés que
vous avez assigné à cette mesure pour
l'année 2015 pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame marisol touraine
ministre de la santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice emery dumas vous mettez
l'accent sur une des dispositions phare
de ce que j'ai appelé le pacte
territoire santé qui comportait qui
comporte toujours 12 mesures pour
faciliter l'implantation de
professionnels de santé dans des
territoires qui en manquent
et parmi ces douze mesures dont
l'incitation à créer des maisons plus
riffs professionnels et les centres de
santé qui figurait déjà dans ce pacte
territoire santé il y à la création des
praticiens territoriaux de médecine g
béral qui ont rencontré un très grand
succès ce sont des jeunes médecins
généralistes pour le moment qui sont
incités à aller s'installer dans des
territoires sous dotés notamment à
travers des dispositions de couverture
sociale qui sont améliorées ce
dispositif a rencontré un grand succès
il y en aura bientôt 400 il en a 17 dans
votre région de bourgogne que et il a
rencontré un tel succès que nous avons
souhaité j'ai souhaité élargir le
dispositif puisque des élus comme
vous-même ont fait remonter la nécessité
d'inciter à l'installation de
spécialistes et la dette dernière loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale a
donc prévu la création de ces praticiens
territoriaux de médecine ambulatoire
l'objectif pour l'année 2015
c'est 200 installations de ces jeunes
médecins spécialistes qui peuvent être
des pédiatres des ophtalmos toutes
spécialités qui répondrait à une demande
locale et qui là encore sont encouragées
en particulier par la mise en place
d'une couverture sociale améliorer qui
est particulièrement intéressante pour
les jeunes femmes médecins vous le voyez
madame la sénatrice nous travaillons
pour faire en sorte que les médecins les
jeunes professionnels est en vie soit
incité à aller s'installer dans les
territoires où les patients attendent de
nouveaux médecins
madame emery du bas merci beaucoup
madame la ministre de ces précisions qui
vont je crois dans le bon sens pour nos
zones rurales sous dotées parce que
comme un certain nombre de collègues
l'eau l'on manifestait il est important
que le patient puisse avoir le choix de
son médecin
mais pour ça il faut effectivement que
le choix puissent exister sur les sur
les territoires et les mesures que que
vous préconisez sont de nature à
permettre un meilleur choix
une meilleure offre territoriale merci
merci la parole est maintenant à votre
collègue madame catherine de roche pour
le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre depuis plusieurs mois et
j'avais eu l'occasion de vous alerter en
décembre dernier votre projet de loi
provoque colère et inquiétudes des
professionnels de santé devant une
mobilisation sans précédent vous aviez
dû reporté une première fois l'examen de
la loi santé à la mi février ce sera
finalement fin mars après la grande
manifestation des internes et des
praticiens libéraux le 15 mars prochain
que ce texte décrié sera examiné à
l'assemblée nationale
à ce sujet je voudrais souligner l'unité
de l'ensemble des syndicats unité
suffisamment rare en effet pour la
mettre en exergue
parmi les mesures qui provoquent des
crispations la généralisation du tiers
payant
outre un risque de déresponsabilisation
des patients tous les syndicats de
médecins
même ceux qui vous sont plutôt
favorables dénonce la complexité de la
mesure et la surcharge de travail
qu'elle va générer pour les médecins à
l'occasion de sa conférence de presse le
5 février dernier le président de la
république avait annoncé je cite que le
tiers payant ne sera mis en place que si
un mécanisme simple est trouvée pour les
professionnels de santé les
problématiques sont connus vérification
des droits des assurés
mise à jour des droits sans parler de la
gestion des impayés auquel les médecins
vont devoir de faire face en cas de
problème de droit de changement de
caisse de carte vitale qui ne sont plus
à jour
les médecins seront désormais payés par
l'assurance maladie par les
complémentaires santé
soit plus de 600 organismes que les
médecins devront contacter en cas de
problème de remboursement
le coût estimé du tiers payant est de
l'ordre de 3 euros 50 par acte qui va
s'occuper de cette surcharge
administrative
les médecins vous allez sans doute nous
dire que ce système fonctionne très bien
dans les pharmacies mais les médecins
n'ont pas de secrétariat pour s'occuper
du tiers payant donc je souhaiterais
savoir en est la digne gociations en
cours à ce sujet je n'ai pas parlé deux
autres sujets qui fâchent tests tels que
le service public hospitalier
des cliniques et la recentralisation des
pouvoirs autour de la rs c'est vrai que
votre projet de loi inquiète beaucoup
les professionnels de santé et si on
doit s'attaquer aux enjeux stratégiques
au déséquilibre de notre système de
santé
il m'en doute pour certains un
attachement réel du gouvernement à la
médecine libérale qui pourtant fait aux
côtés de nos hôpitaux publics la
réputation d'excellence
notre pays bien pour vous répondre la
parole des tca madame marisol touraine
ministre de la santé
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice de roche ce projet de loi de
santé
quel est son ambition son ambition c'est
de faire en sorte que certaines
inégalités de santé puisse être réduite
avant si l'on pouvait espérer les faire
disparaître mais d'être réduite et cela
passe notamment par la facilitation de
l'accès aux soins
cela passe aussi par le développement de
la prévention c'est à dire le fait de
pouvoir aller voir des professionnels
pour être accompagnés et pas simplement
soigner et par d'autres mesures de ce
type là
le tiers payant est une des mesures qui
est ainsi proposé le tiers payant existe
déjà et environ 30% des actes des
professionnels des médecins je ne parle
pas des pharmaciens 30% des actes sont
réalisés en tiers payant
les bénéficiaires de la cmu bénéficient
déjà du tiers payant les anciens détenus
pendant une période transitoire
bénéficie du tiers payant les malades à
la suite d'accidents du travail ou de
maladie professionnelle bénéficie du
tiers payant et il ya donc eu des étapes
on pourrait aussi parler des cabinets de
radiologie des cabinets de biologie dans
lesquels il y as souvent le tiers payant
donc l'objectif c'est évidemment de
réfléchir à un dispositif qui soit
simple il n'est pas question de
complexité administrative
un système qui est des garanties de
paiement qui peuvent être inscrites dans
la loi
madame la sénatrice je n'ai aucun
problème pour cela et c'est un
engagement que j'ai pris et auquel
autour duquel nous travaillons avec les
financeurs et avec les professionnels de
santé et donc si nous devons travailler
à cela c'est pour garantir un système
qui ne coûtent pas l'argent qui ne
coûtent pas de temps aux professionnels
de santé
et c'est le sens des discussions qui
sont actuellement menées et je souhaite
que nous puissions trouver
des dispositifs qui satisfasse les
préoccupations de chacun merci madame la
ministre
merci madame bureau ministre en effet
j'entends bien en effet certains sont
déjà au tiers payant
néanmoins ce qui inquiète c'est une
généralisation qui en terme de temps
sera quand même beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus lourdes pour les cabinets et et si
en effet on peut parler des laboratoires
des cervidés des centres de radiologie
le médecin généraliste qui est tout seul
chez lui sans secrétaire souvent un ci
doit en plus faire sa comptabilité le
soir avec la complexité que ça
représente moi je l' ai vécu à titre
personnel et familial
c'est très lourd parfois je dire ils
n'ont plus le temps de se centrer sur
leur véritable mission alors vous ne
dites on va trouver un procédé simple
mais c'est ce qu'ils attendent depuis
des mois que vous leur disais quel sera
le procédé simple et quelle sera la
procédure simple qui ne justement ne
fasse pas cela bon pour l'instant n'a
toujours pas la réponse
chers collègues la parole et à notre
collègue daniel chelle ça pour le groupe
union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame le ministre
ma question madame la miss décompose en
trois parties la première question a
trait à la situation des médecins
libéraux en zone rurale ou hyper rurales
qui sont de moins en moins nombreux un
pont vouloir s'y installer alors pour
toutes sortes de raisons qui ne sont
rien exhaustive l'impossibilité de
travailler plus de seulement 35 heures
les difficultés liées aux inévitables
des placements sur des distances longues
l'idée peut-être aussi que les cabinets
en zone rurale sont moins rentable qu'en
zone urbaine
enfin tout ça risque d'entraîner des
déserts médicaux je vous demande ainsi
votre sentiment sur un projet plusieurs
fois évoqué ici ou ailleurs et qui à ce
jour ne s'est pas concrétisée attribuées
aux étudiants en médecine une allocation
annuelle d'état qui pourraient deux
trois quatre cinq mille euros à partir
de la deuxième année
jusqu'à la cinquième année cela pourrait
être un ascenseur social à condition
qu'ils s'engagent à s'installer en
milieu rural pour un certain nombre
d'années
dix ans par exemple en effet la
combinaison des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires et des subventions
après le diplôme ne subira pas même si
c'est un plus le deuxième porte sur le
numerus clausus nous sommes nombreux à
penser qu'il faut l'élargir
si l'on veut un jour faire face aux
besoins sanitaires d'aujourd'hui de
demain actuellement en effet le nombre
de médecins soient ressortissants de la
communauté européenne soit tout
bonnement étrangers s'installent en
france au détriment des étudiants en
médecine français qui reste au bord des
eaux qui restent aux portes de la
faculté en raison d'un examen hyper
sélectifs dans lequel on exige une
moyenne de notes supérieures à ce qui
est demandé dans d'autres pays
10 en roumanie en particulier contre 13
ou 14 en france cette situation est donc
non seulement injuste la moitié des
médecins sont des étrangers dans les
hôpitaux périphériques au détriment de
nos compatriotes mais aussi
problématique puisque au bout du compte
le résultat est qu'on manque de médecins
en france troisième point concerne les
maternités offrant un seuil inférieur à
300 accouchements par an dont un récent
rapport de la cour des comptes prône la
fermeture le problème est que plusieurs
d'entre elles sont situées en milieu
rural ou hyper rural et en plus je fait
un service évident de proximité à
condition bien sûr de garantir au
travail en équipe avec des équipes avec
des maternités de type iii où l'on
trouve des équipes de réanimation
néonatale et des réductions plus riantes
je conclus c'est le cas de celle du sel
dans mon département qui si elle
disparaissait créerait un vide dans les
services de proximité une situation de
danger pour les parturientes domicilié à
plus d'une heure de voiture d'une
structure de rechange romerio madame la
ministre vous avez un peu consommé votre
temps de répliques mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur
chacin plusieurs questions en effet vous
évoquez d'abord le sujet du numerus
clausus que j'ai abordé la france ne
manque pas de médecin il y as par
habitant par millier d'habitants plus de
médecins en france aujourd'hui qu'il y a
vingt ans la difficulté à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés c'est leur
concentration dans certains territoires
au détriment d'autres territoires
d'où les mesures qui que j'ai mise en
place pour inciter les jeunes
professionnels à aller s'installer dans
des territoires sous dotées et parmi ces
mesures monsieur le sénateur il y à la
mise en place de bourses de bourse qui
vont de 800 à 1500 euros par mois et qui
permettent aux étudiants en médecine
mais aussi désormais aux étudiants en
odontologie de bénéficier d'un soutien
pendant leurs études
en échange de quoi ils s'engagent à
s'installer pendant un certain nombre
d'années dans des territoires dans
lesquels il n'y a pas suffisamment de
professionnels de santé ce dispositif
rencontre un grand succès puisque 881
étudiants très exactement ou internes
ont opté en 2014 pour le versement d'une
bourse
en contrepartie de cette installation et
76 contrats ont été signés avec des
étudiants en odontologie c'est une
nouveauté que j'ai introduit donc en
2013 et dans votre région limousin 22 de
ces contrats ont ainsi été signés vous
évoquez enfin monsieur le sénateur le
cas de maternités comme celle du sel
disons les choses simplement
dès qu'ils font moins de 300
accouchements par an la cour des comptes
n'a pas indiqué qu'il fallait fermer ces
maternités
elle a demandé à ce qu'il soit qu'on
soit attentifs à leurs conditions de
sécurité et c'est le cas notamment à
ussel puisqu'il y a eu un renforcement
des équipes de gynécologues
obstétriciens pédiatre et anesthésiste
qui permettent de conduire des
coopérations médical avec les
établissements voisins c'est donc une
réponse adaptée qui est apportée dans
nos territoires
allez quelques secondes monsieur chasse
sympa rebonds
absolue en ce qui concerne pour moi et
beaucoup d'autres noms d'élargissement
du numerus clausus qui n'est pas récent
mais qui est constant depuis 15 ans
semble une faute très préjudiciable pour
nos territoires
nos hôpitaux nos enfants qui aurait
sûrement été des praticiens motivés se
seraient installés en milieu rural merci
qui mon cher collègue serait maintenant
suspendre la séance en remerciant madame
la ministre plus cher collègue et frère
de questions cribles thématiques sur le
thème de la situation de la médecine
libérale en france la ministre de la
santé marisol touraine répondait au
sénateur beaucoup de questions portaient
sur son projet de loi santé un projet de
loi très critique et très controversée
certains se sont inquiétés comme la
socialiste michelle meunier de la
suppression de la libre installation des
médecins libéraux
la réponse de la ministre a été
immédiate et très claire la libre
installation n'a pas été n'est pas et ne
sera pas remise en question par le
gouvernement en revanche la ministre de
la santé a un peu moins rassurer les
sénateurs quant à la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux elle prôné dire le
développement des maisons de santé et
l'incitation des jeunes médecins à
s'installer dans les zones sous dotées
et puis la ministre n'a pas du tout
convaincu les sénateurs de droite de la
majorité ici au sénat comme la
vice-présidente ump isabelle debré quand
elle l'interrogé sur l'esprit de sa loi
pas convaincu non plus par et bien
l'avenir de la relation entre les
médecins et leurs patients des médecins
libéraux qui risque d'être de plus en
plus surchargées par l'administration
voilà ce qu'il fallait retenir de ces
questions cribles thématiques très bonne
journée à vous sur les chaînes
parlementaires